boa noite parabéns a toda poderosa estão
organizando
o evento fiquei muito feliz em ser
convidado muito intenso também vai
estrear paulo pede para falar com esse
público é o tipo de situação que tiver
sua máquina do tempo apertado um botão
fugir daqui bom aqui a gente já tem o
primeiro ponto sobre tempo e tecnologia
ainda bem que essa marca não existe
enquanto os desafios quantas barreiras
quanto os aprendizados
a gente tem porque a gente não tenha
possibilidade de recuar depois que a
gente resolve seguir em frente ao paço
a gente vai aprendi melhora se supera um
objetivo final
o objetivo final hoje aqui meu é sair
com vocês um pouco melhor porque como é
que comecei antes desse 18 minutos aqui
é bom tem 47 anos
nasci no interior de minas na cidade
pequena chamada que o júri tinha mais ou
menos mil habitantes
três ruas debaixo de senha do meio e lá
na década de 70 o tempo quase não andava
e isso era bom porque tinha brincadeiras
na rua com os amigos na rua a
brincadeira sozinho com os índios com
soldadinhos com os monstros feitos de
legumes e palitos de fósforo o chuchu e
à bn janeiro que dá as berinjelas que dá
os mais interessantes muito distante
nesta dos canais do youtube dos jogos de
realidade virtual mais que nós temos
hoje mas lá naquela época já a
tecnologia é meio que batia na minha
porta é dizendo que talvez através dela
eu atuaria profissionalmente e teria a
possibilidade de ajudar e tentar
melhorar a vida das pessoas
lembro que não tinha relógio o relógio
era hora de a fome bate a gol na hora do
almoço a mãe gritando que de hoje aquele
momento durante o banho não ia escapar
então nessa época meu tio tinha um cara
muito gente boa fez uma uso foi estudar
na europa quando ele voltou e trouxe um
relógio de relógio digital tocava 12
músicas você programar o relógio
determinadas datas e naquela data a loja
toca
a música de hora em hora que mais me
marcou era o dia do aniversário dela
parabéns a você de hora em hora e no dia
do aniversário de casamento dos meus
pais
tocava marcha nupcial de hora em hora
as pessoas paravam para pra ficar vendo
aquela situação não é boa porque as
pessoas paravam para quê tanta marcha
nupcial para quê tanta admiração é
justamente a fascinação que a tecnologia
em causa na gente então é isso isso
marcou muito essa fascinação que a
tecnologia ali era um divisor de águas
era o marco tecnológico mais tarde
quando tinha mais ou menos os 12 anos
é é meu pai é um cara visionário ele se
liga muito em educação apesar de não ter
conseguido terminar os estudos e se
preparar para trabalhar com meu avô a
família grande dez irmãos e minha mãe
também que era professora e também muito
ligado à educação me der um computador
era um é k 83 2k de memória
o objetivo era que eu aprendesse a
programar para poder controlar o estoque
da loja em que trabalhava
poderia jogar também mas não era estudar
o davi principal para ligar o computador
era um é um ritual porque tinha um
computador
nesta fita cassete que colocava no
gravador ligado cabo no computador na
televisão sair um som muito doido
gravador o computador tinha captar esse
som enfim quando funcionava era uma
maravilha
mais tarde eu comprei uma expansão de 16
carros
essa aqui aí agora eu tinha 18 casa de
memória bom não tenho que fazer muita
coisa
quando eu terminei esse texto para falar
com vocês hoje só o texto deu 24 carros
um com 18 carlos deu para programar
muito não
nem virei um grande programador mas foi
ótimo abriu minha cabeça que é
importante na cidade todo mundo queria
conhecer o tal do computador
então foi bom porque eu fiquei
importante na época lá e mais ajudou
abriu minha cabeça ajudou a não ter medo
do desconhecido e sabia que estava
acontecendo muitas coisas diferentes
possibilidades incríveis
é aconteceu fora da aquela pequena
querida cidade é hoje eu trabalho em
três frentes mercado financeiro
estratégia de comunicação digital e com
tecnologia
são três frentes é juntas na qual o
tempo anda muito rápido e à tecnologia
voa na velocidade exponencial
é nessa nessa nessa área a gente tem um
desafio muito grande
apesar de todas a esse turbilhão
tecnológico é porque nessas três áreas
juntas a novidade de hoje virar peça de
museu amanhã as verdades irão
questionamentos muito muito rápido então
nesse turbilhão tecnológica a gente tem
um desafio muito grande que a educação
financeira que existe um gap muito
grande de educação financeira hoje no
país
então a gente tem o desafio de romper as
barreiras entre as pessoas
o dinheiro um propósito através do
trabalho de melhorar a vida financeira
das pessoas que hoje estão melhorando a
vida financeira também melhora a vida
física que quando o bolso adoece adoece
estômago dessa cabeça é adoece coração
então é um desafio grande no brasil
existe uma barreira cultural muito
grande uma dificuldade muito grande de
falar sobre dinheiro
falamos pouco em casa falamos quase nada
nas escolas
compramos de acordo com a prestação que
cabe no nosso bolso sem fazer conta dos
juros às vezes e devia ser sempre a
gente pede desconto de 10 reais uma
conta de 100 mas não pede redes conta de
um real na conta de 10
ambos são 10% de um de dez em dez
conjuntos composto ano a gente tem uma
diferença significativa no nosso
património longo prazo
a gente trabalha há 40 50 60 300 horas
por mês ea hora que a gente recebe
salário recebe o bônus recebe dinheiro a
gente não para uma hora
para tentar ver que a gente pode
economizar o que a gente pode
comprometer a forma da gente investir
qual a melhor forma de colocar o
dinheiro pra efetivamente daquele
momento começar a trabalhar pra gente
mas está mudando graças à tecnologia
está mudando de uma forma que já é vista
e não a dá pra para todos os
participantes do mercado nessa situação
são algoritmos ferramentas entendendo
melhor o perfil das pessoas produtos que
antes eram restritos não há poucas
pessoas já estão mais acessíveis a uma
camada maior da população
compartilhamento dos vídeos blogs and é
toda toda tecnologia é envolvida nesse
processo a gente está vivendo uma
verdadeira revolução tecnológica
financeira mas uma coisa que a gente não
deve cair na armadilha não deve se
enganar é que a tecnologia muito rápida
mas o tempo de aprendizado ele não
acompanha essa velocidade da tecnologia
e isso o tempo o tempo de aprendizado
necessita maturação e cita entendimento
esse finanças é gritante
por mais tecnológico que seja o processo
de investir por mais rápido que seja o
processo de vestir os investimentos para
dar resultado precisam de paciência
maturação tempo para estratégias
consolidar isso não está acontecendo só
com os investimentos acontecendo na
nossa vida também é a gente se depara
com uma coisa nova
o melhor que ela seja ela também tem seu
lado negativo
ela tem um lado negro da força ea
tecnologia nesse sentido em algumas
coisas que a gente tem que tomar muito
cuidado
é essa velocidade que ela impõe muitas
vezes o tempo de aprendizado não
acompanha
por exemplo hoje é um fato presente
ficar 50% mais ou menos as pessoas se
dizem formadas só em título da notícia à
pressa e acha que tá ok
pior que isso a gente hoje está lendo só
notícias que nos interessam
só dos grupos
nós freqüentamos só notícias que a rede
social não moro nos mostra que muitas
vezes através de algoritmos já sabem que
aquela notícia que a gente quer ler ela
mostra só o nosso ponto de vista e
quando chega uma coisa diferente
quando chega uma coisa que não que não
bate com o nosso ponto de vista chega em
forma de m chega em forma de piada e com
isso a gente está perdendo o poder de
análise o poder crítico
a gente tá é colocando de viseira do
cavalo e te seguindo um efeito manada
a gente não está parando pra analisar
para ver a beleza do contraditório
tá buscar informações de verdade que vão
que não são a informação do nosso ponto
de vista é é há algum tempo atrás o
grande desafio nosso
ela busca do conteúdo nas escolas os
nossos pais comprando cico enciclopédia
que era nosso google da época
hoje nosso desafio é outro nosso desafio
é lidar com o excesso de conteúdo você
dá um google você tem acesso a tudo
o nosso desafio hoje é ser crítico é
analisar é digerir esse conteúdo e para
isso a gente precisa de tempo
sem o tempo a gente não consegue fazer
isso porque a gente está realmente
perdendo a beleza do contraditório
a discussão salutar então está perdendo
é e nos privando de às vezes ser um
pouco o que o raul seixas cantor
prefiro ser essa metamorfose ambulante
do que ter aquela velha opinião formada
sobre tudo é uma coisa também que tem me
chamado muita atenção e tem preocupado
bastante trabalhando com os jovens é a
ansiedade que o descompasso entre o
tempo ea tecnologia está causando né
esse descompasso entre até o tempo a
tecnologia está realmente causando uma
ansiedade muito grande nos jovens
eu vou contar uma história que aconteceu
comigo o tempo atrás talvez possa
exemplificá isso melhor
é tão a música do legião urbana que diz
comprei uma passagem foi direto à
salvador há uns anos para cá uns anos
atrás eu comprei a passagem foi direto a
el salvador
comecei a surfar com 35 anos foi a
melhor decisão que eu tomei na minha
vida
contato com a natureza troca de energia
com o mar foco disciplina é támbém de
saúde para poder ter essa sensação
maravilhosa entender os meus limites e
entender os limites do mar e paciência
não adianta querer entrar em todas as
ondas na vida também assim não adianta
querer entrar em todas as ondas e
principalmente entender a diferença
entre a percepção e realidade quando às
vezes quando eu desci uma onda quando
chegou no final acho que isso foi melhor
que o kelly slater ritto ferreira joão
flores junto à ilha depois que eu vou
ver a gol prova os filmes as force
dentro e fora d'água vejo que as coisas
não muito longe não é bem assim que a
banda toca é bom enfim com pressa
passagem porque precisava é é a passar
por um momento difícil decisão difícil
da minha vida eu estava desconectá
precisava parar eu precisava parar o
tempo dá um tempo entender desconectados
todo esse turbilhão tecnológico que a
gente vive
quando eu voltei eu vi que eu fiz isso
porque vinha uma na atividade que eu
tenho hoje estava pensando em desistir a
passar para outro desafio
não era a primeira vez que isso que se
acontecer várias vezes eu brigava tudo
de mim
lutava e saiu do desafio pra outra sem
sem concluir
eu falei que dessa vez poderia fazer mas
seria diferente tinha que ter um tempo
para parar pra pensar melhor nisso
quando eu voltei eu vi que nada tinha
mudado
a foto é igual só que eu vi as coisas de
uma forma diferente a desconexão fez
muito bem
eu fiz vi as coisas com a nova
perspectiva
eu parei de buscar os fatos e as
informações que estavam levando pra só
tomar aquela decisão continue olhando os
fatos informações não só eles
venha me interar a ver as coisas a
conversar com as pessoas as duas coisas
sob nova perspectiva conversei com minha
família minha esposa minhas filhas que
me ajudam a tomar as decisões e resolvi
que dessa vez é fazer diferente é dessa
vez resolvi resolvi ficar aí trabalhando
com jovens das pessoas entrar no mercado
de trabalho
eu tô vendo que este ano piorando cada
vez mais essa ansiedade está piorando
cada vez mais ganhar dinheiro rápido e
sucesso rápido reconhecimento rápido
colocar os projetos para formar
instantaneamente porque é assim que a
tecnologia nos molda e assim que a
tecnologia moldada através dos métodos
ágeis os agilis os métodos de
programação de programação rápido os
sucessos instantâneos da rede social é o
sucesso tanto na rede social parece que
instantâneo mas não é a gente sabe
quanto trabalho as empresas e as pessoas
fizeram para ter aquele sucesso
é a famosa frase não tem sorte não é
instantâneo é um trabalho danado ter
sorte um trabalho danado 6 santa então
gente o que eu quero dizer para vocês o
seguinte o interessante o importante
entendir com esse processo todo uma
frase que meu pai não vou contar com o
meu pai e meu pai e petistas antigamente
ouvia mas entende a pedra que muito roda
não cria luto não tinha tem que esperar
um tempinho e chá pedra pegá-lo do as
coisas precisam de tempo para acontecer
por mais que a tecnologia nos ajuda mas
a gente tem que estar atento porque a
tecnologia ela fascina fascinou com
relógio tocava 12 músicas fascina
toda vez que a gente tem contato com uma
coisa nova
agora a gente tem que ter cuidado com
essa fascinação não nos pilotis a
entender que a tecnologia é uma
ferramenta poderosíssima
ela por si só não é nada mas é uma
cabe à gente a escolha da nossa mão como
é que a gente vai usar
lamenta se é para nos roubar tempo você
é para nos dar tempo para as coisas que
realmente importa na vida dar tempo para
fazermos as coisas certas no tempo que a
gente tem aqui no mundo
muito obrigado gente num